والسيد وسام عفيفه في رايك ماذا يمكن ان
يكون اثر هذه الرشقات الصاروخيه على اي
مفاوضات تتم مع الجانب الاسرائيلي من خلال
وسطاء طبعا في الفتره
المقبله مما لا شك فيها هذه تعد احد اوراق
القوه لدى المقاومه اذا كنا نتحدث عن
الاسرى بحد ذاته ورقه القوه الكبيره
والاولى لكن ايضا قدره المقاومه على
الاستمرار في اطلاق الصواريخ وهنا لا
اتحدث فقط عن المديات المرتبطه بما يسمى
غلاف غزه ولكن المدى هنا يتحدث عن وسط
اسرائيل فلذ رتاج دوله الاحتلال بينما
الدبابات تعبر وتمر في مناطق وسط مدينه
غزه تعلن صافرات الانذار مجددا ان هناك
فشل وفشل كبير وعندما
يضطر الاسرائيليون التوجه نحو المناجي كما
جاء في اعلان حتى الجيش الغريب وهو يتحدث
انه بعد 74 يوما فرات ضط الدوي والمواطنين
يبحثون عن ملاجئ هذا هذا اعلان بمثابه
اعلان اولا فشل واعلان احباط وا بالتاكيد
هذا الامر يحبط اكبر او يفشل اكبر هدف او
الهدف الاول وهو القضاء على حماس كيف يمكن
لدبابه و وجنود يذهبوا للبحث عن قياده
حماس وعن انفاق حماس داخل غزه بينما
تستطيع هذه القياده السيطره والتحكم
بمواعيد وتوقيت وعدد الصواريخ التي تطلق
على اسرائيل ليس فقط تنظيم وترتيب و توجيه
القوات على الارض في حالات المواجهه
الحاصله في غزه هذا يعني ان الاهداف اصبحت
ان لم تكن مستحيله فهي بعيده المنار وهم
الان بداوا يتحدثوا بالمناسبه عن الفترات
الزمنيه الطويله بداوا يعترفوا ان الامر
يستغرق شهور وربما سنوات وحتى مع زياره
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لوست لوي اوستن واضح
انهم لا يحاولوا اليوم ان يتحدثوا عن
جداول زمنيه قريب هم يطلبوا دائما شهور
ويطلبوا فترات زمنيه ب حتى لا لا يريدوا
ان يرتبطوا بجداول زمنيه لانه اي موعد او
اي توقيت يحددو سوف ينقلب كحاله فشل
ويسجل كهزيم تكتيكيه على على مسار طويل من
هذه المواجهه وبالتالي قدره الحماس على
الاستمرار باطلاق الصواريخ هذا وسافرات
اصدار تدوي هذا يعني انها سوف تدوي في
اذان الكابينه كابنه الحرب باعتبارها جس
انذار انكم فشلتم الوقت ينفذ امامكم
وبالتاكيد اصواتها سوف تؤثر على معنويات
الجبه الداخليه وحاله الاجماع خلف الجيش
حاله
ال الدافعيه بانه يمكن من خلال عمليه
عسكريه القضاء على حماس ربما كان يعتقد من
خلال حديث الكابينت الحرب ان الامر قد
يستغرق بضعه اسابيع شهر شهرين ربما ثلاثه
وبالتالي تنتهي هذه المعاناه يبدو
انها لم تكون حاضره لن تكون حاضره في
الوقت القريب وبالتالي صافرات انظار سوف
تذكر الجبه الداخليه الاسرائيلي ان هناك
اخفاق كبير ولن يتح كبير شكرا جزيلا شكرا
جزيلا لك من دير البلح الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي وسيم وسام عفيفه